It's a huge talking point for socialists. And here's why,
because they've always been held to this standard of, well,
how are you going to pay for it?
So modern monetary theory is, well,
we'll just digitize or print the money. Well,
that sounds like old failed monetary policy,
but this is new. And the idea is,
is that as long as everybody understands that we can just
print the money and if we need the money,
we're going to have to tax everybody to death,
but we're not going to need the money.
So we'll just make the money and then we'll spend the money and that will help
us make more money, modern monetary theory.
And if there's inflation, we'll use price controls. Uh,
and we'll also use taxes to make sure that people are buying only the things
that we want them to buy.
This is total control of an economy through a government,
through the printing of dollars. That's modern monetary theory.
How afraid are you generally that we're just going to kind of keep giving away
these things that, that the time the calendar we'll keep marching and slowly,
yeah, we won't go in our cars. We won't leave our house.
Suddenly walking your dog will be a problem. And you'll, you know,
it can only go in the backyard or just like the endless cascade of things that
we can think of.
But I'm more worried about the things that we can't think of that they could
come for.
So here's the, here's the worst part, um,
in the book, um, arguing with socialists, uh, you have a copy there,
open it up chapter six. Yeah. Open it up to chapter six. Okay.
Uh, I don't know if you, if you saw that one,
but it's how technology and modern monetary theory can make socialism more
dangerous than ever. Um, this is, this was,
this was assuming that the economic collapse would come over a
slow long period of time, uh,
that the economic collapse would,
and joblessness would happen maybe because of technology. The,
in that chapter,
I outline what happens in that situation where it's lots of
joblessness.
The first thing that happens is the government needs to spend more money.
And so they start to print more money, um,
printed in the last few weeks more money.
Then we, uh,
we digitized more money than we could have printed in a year.
You literally could not print that.
There's not enough trees to print the amount of money that we have just
digitized in a two or three week period.
It's not about the gold anymore.
It's not about the dollars cause we can't print them fast enough.
Now we're just truly in a sort of imaginary.
It's. So it is called.
It is called modern monetary theory. Have you ever heard of it, Dave?
I haven't man. This is a huge, no, no, no, no.
Most people don't know it. It's a huge talking point for socialists.
And here's why, because they've always been held to this standard of, well,
how are you going to pay for it?
So modern monetary theory is, well,
we'll just digitize or print the money. Well,
that sounds like old failed monetary policy,
but this is new. And the idea is,
is that as long as everybody understands that we can just
print the money and if we need the money,
we're going to have to tax everybody to death,
but we're not going to need the money.
So we'll just make the money and then we'll spend the money and that will help
us make more money, modern monetary theory.
And if there's inflation, we'll use price controls. Uh,
and we'll also use taxes to make sure that people are buying only the things
that we want them to buy.
This is total control of an economy through a government,
through the printing of dollars. That's modern monetary theory.
The fed is doing it right now, but the UK treasury,
the crown just announced that they are using monitoring modern
monetary theory. And they are actually just printing the deck.
They're at least admitting it. We're doing it as well. In this chapter,
I talk about when that starts,
the government is going to know it needs tech and tech will
know it needs the government.
And so the tech and the government will start to work together to monitor people
because they'll need to monitor and track, et cetera, et cetera.
The Corona virus has made chapter six, a reality. It is.
You asked me, you know, how nervous are you?
I'm terrified that what I wrote in chapter six is happening
right now.
Oh, okay. So there's so much there. So, so jumping from that,
which will sort of lead us further into the book. So how much of this,
the situation that we're in right now,
do you think was just because our systems were collapsing in
front of us, we were watching the media system collapse in front of us.
We were watching academia collapse in front of us.
We were watching the political establishment collapse and that all of those
collapses.
And then you find a crisis that you can throw in the middle of that lead to this
perfect stew where suddenly numbers don't even mean anything.
And we have new monetary policy.
Okay. So let me, let me answer it this way. You know, the,
the Reichstag fire.
Of course never let a good crisis go to waste.
Correct. Now the Germans said,
let's separate this from what we know, let me give you two aspects or two,
two answers on this one. The German said that that fire was happening.
And then, uh, the, the Nazis just took advantage of it. That's one version.
The other version is, uh, no, they started it.
They wanted it to burn. Uh, and then they used that fire.
So I don't think, I don't think that that is what happened here.
I don't think anyone started this fire.
I don't think that while I do believe that this did come from bats
that were, you know,
the specimens were collected by the Chinese and brought to that lab.
It was not released intentionally. It was sloppy.
So nobody created this crisis. Um,
and then it's a series of events that just spiral out of control.
But I do believe at some point somebody came in and went, you know,
this whole thing is melting down. Anyway,
this might be a good time just to pull the plug.
I do think that's a possibility, um, man,
we just have the craziest people in charge.
Yeah, it's weird because we all sort of become conspiracy theories, theorists,
and then it's like, well, what's really a conspiracy, not you.
Cause what you're saying is it's not that it's some coordinated thing
necessarily, but events transpire and feed off each other.
And next thing you know, here we are.
And you not only have events feed off each other,
you do have bad actors. For instance, China is now telling France,
we can help you out all you want, but you have to take our 5g, uh,
systems. We'll give you all the masks that you need,
but we'll only sell them to you if you do. So you have bad actors doing that.
And I do think that there are those who are in, uh,
uh, global positions, be them people, uh, uh,
that are, you know, in high tech or in, uh,
high finance or governments that do want a different system that
don't believe in the system of the West. Uh,
and they would like to use an opportunity to their advantage.
I don't think it's a conspiracy theory to think that people, you know,
actually believe don't let a crisis go to waste.
Especially since many people in positions of power have been saying it out
loud recently. You know, if you look at what, uh,
the Fabian socialists did in world war one,
we wouldn't have gone to war.
If there weren't a group of people that were saying,
this is actually going work to our advantage, um,
we should go to world war because we can change the world closer to our heart's
desire. That's what they did then. And I think it,
it, it plays some role here.
So it's interesting because all of this actually is sort of directly related to
why you're constantly arguing with socialists.
But before we get into the book specifically,
just one more thing on this generally,
what do you make of the role or the state of media right now?
I know you and I are in agreement on just watching mainstream media collapsed
and in many, and in many ways it should,
but like just in the last couple of days,
this insane New York times story that sort of defended Biden because there's
no evidence, even though that wasn't the standard they held Brett Kavanaugh to,
or, or a million other examples I can give lately of just, you know,
Corona related nonsense and you know, two months ago,
it's not going to be a problem now they're, they're screaming, fire. I mean,
all of this,
cause that's another piece of this that I think has just run Ram shot
basically across everybody and nobody knows who to trust right now.
So, um, it's a crisis of trust in almost everything.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.